many of you probably have seen over the
last 24 to 48 hours that there are
reports circulating that the united
states and the irs are not going to tax
crypto gains that are derived from
staking or mining well before we get too
into this this may not actually be
exactly true so let's dig into exactly
what's happening here first there's a
couple in nashville tennessee the
jarretts they have requested a refund of
3 293 of income tax that they previously
paid in 2019 after they received 8 800
tezos tokens the couple is also seeking
a 500 increase in tax credits for lost
income the irs and the courts have been
looking at this case in detail the
reason why is that these tokens were
obtained through proof of stake
protocols those are taxpayer-created
property according to the jarretts and
taxpayer created property is not
actually supposed to be taxed until it
is sold or exchanged and so ultimately
what the government the irs the courts
etc are all going to have to decide is
how are they going to treat these
staking tokens well the irs decided that
they should refund the taxes related to
those unsold tasos tokens that refund
would be a reward that could have proven
exactly what the jarrods are claiming
but the plaintiffs rejected that refund
and they want a formal policy statement
obviously they are spending a lot of
money and it's not simply to recoup
three thousand dollars or to get 500
worth of lost income they're trying to
force the hand of the irs and the
government and the courts to say if we
stake and actually receive tokens from
staking or if we mine tokens and do not
sell or exchange them do we have to pay
taxes on them or not this would be a
massive massive boom to the industry if
all of a sudden every single miner could
say i don't have to pay taxes on what i
mine until i either sell the tokens or i
exchange them for another one same could
be said for proof of stake blockchains
as well
now it is important to understand the
reason why i say that the mainstream
narrative that the irs will not tax
crypto in 2022 may not exactly be true
is because the irs is simply trying to
offer a refund here there has been no
policy updated there has been no
definitive agreement yet the hope of the
industry is that that is coming but we
do not have it yet and so ultimately
what we are all waiting for is to see
where this case ends up if the jareds
prevail and the irs says that proof of
stake tokens that you accumulate and do
not sell or exchange or tokens that are
accumulated through the mining process
that you do not sell or exchange there
is no taxation on it all of a sudden i
think you'll see it an absolute tailwind
for those types of activities in the
crypto industry there's billions of
dollars of value being created and if
you don't have to pay income tax you
don't have to pay capital gains tax
until you sell or exchange them that's
going to be a really really big deal